Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bird.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
May 2nd,
and I know,
I always make that joke like,
oh my God,
where is it here going.
But seriously guys,
seriously,
where the fuck is this year going?
What the fuck?
May 2nd already may fucking second.
But getting ready for this,
um,
in the meg,
I'm psyched.
I'm psyched that we're into May.
Cause may means we're closer to the middle of July and in the middle of the Jill
of July I will be done writing,
you know,
helping to write the second season of f is for family.
And then I'm,
I'm free.
Not really,
but sort of,
and I'll have two weeks off and then all freckles.
Rumor has it is going to be doing a,
doing a nice run through Europe.
So,
uh,
which might may or may not start in Ireland.
It's all a sort of loose at this point.
But uh,
we're slugging it out and um,
I'm actually feeling much better by the way.
Thank you for not asking with my Sayada.
Cyanic and it sounds like a fucking speed metal band,
you know,
not a good one though.
Right?
Come see my band cy Attica.
We're going to be down at the ground round on a Wednesday night.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll definitely see it.
All right,
so like you think maybe you could like bring some people,
hey,
you know,
I'm going to do what I can.
All right,
so is that like,
I definitely put you down,
right
dude,
fuck off.
I'm,
I'll,
if I get there,
I'll get there.
All right bro.
Chill.
Um,
Sciatica.
I'm sorry.
I actually,
I got some,
I found some new stretches.
I found this fucking guy on a,
on youtube does doctor who's just sitting on a yoga mat,
one of these fucking new agey guys,
you know what I mean?
One of those guys that's like straight,
but we're still makes you uncomfortable.
You know those,
you know those straight guys?
Like it's straight up.
Gay Guy is not uncomfortable to be around,
but there's a certain kind of straight guy that's coming off like he's gay,
but he's straight.
That is the most uncomfortable male to be around.
I don't know why.
You know what I mean?
It's almost like they got something between their teeth and you just can't even
hear what the fuck they say.
Do you want to be like,
can you just go and get that the fuck outta here so I can listen to you?
Is there a word for that?
The Gay Straight Guy?
Um,
yeah,
Bill,
it's called a gay guy in Cla.
In,
in the,
in the closet.
Well,
maybe it isn't some,
some guys are just,
uh,
some guys who just a feminine,
some guys just stand there and gym class classes.
One person after another.
Okay.
This call to be on the team.
I,
it's a stereotype,
right?
This gay athletes,
it was that guy who played on a,
the big 12 there in Missouri and then he went to a,
that football team and then he got cut.
It must have been hard to cut him.
Right.
All right.
How bad is this guy?
You have to suck before we won't get accused of being homophobic when we kind
of,
you know,
that's always in the air,
but that's not what I wanted to talk about.
I'm here to talk about siren at the Worcester set drum.
Um,
turns out my hamstring was fucked up so I was doing like the touch at toe
stretches,
which is the exact opposite thing that you want to do because the nerve is
pinched or inflamed and you're just like,
you're,
you're not stretching it out.
What it,
I guess you stretch the muscles really.
So whatever I usually yet,
I don't know,
stretches around the nerve.
I have no idea.
I never even heard of this fucking thing until I had this problem and God knows
I didn't take any anatomy classes.
So,
um,
I think when you don't have a nerve issue,
you can then do that Ben.
Cause what,
what you're stretching really is just your muscle,
your muscle fibers in the muscle tissue.
Um,
and the nerves are just sort of chilling around it.
But when it gets pinched between the,
the fucking anterior cruciate ligament of the lower fucking vertebrate tailbone,
whatever the fuck it is,
all I know is like fuck it.
Fucking pulling a balloon,
um,
on inflate a balloon.
I have no fucking analogy.
I don't know what else I know is it hurts.
So I put this guy on this hippy guy and he was just like,
yeah man,
what she actually want to do is you don't,
then there's certain stretches that you wanted you and use certain strategies
the don't want to do.
And you know,
we're in an age right now and it's,
I'm so fucking impatient.
I was trying to skip ahead by just had to sit there,
you know,
everything I could do just to get through a nine minute video.
It's only nine minutes out of my day,
but there's like a flat screen TV with NBA and Nhl playoffs going on.
I got other videos I can click on.
You know,
as I'm sitting there trying to listen to this guy,
I'm also looking at all the videos on the right,
you know,
there's free porn,
there's all kinds of shit and this guy is just sitting there going,
you know,
okay,
could could stretch that you want to do is is actually,
if you just sit down on your buttocks,
make sure your weight is on your,
your pelvic bones.
And I was just,
it was driving me fucking insane,
but whatever.
I ended up doing the stretches and I and I definitely feel better.
So,
um,
thanks to that guy,
whatever his fucking name is and I will definitely be posting those in case
anybody else has that problem.
If you just sitting down in a chair and like your feet go numb and shit,
you could possibly have what I have.
Oh,
you got a big dog sitting in your lap,
one or the other.
I have no fucking idea,
but I'm just happy that it,
uh,
that it feels better and um,
I got to tell you all these fucking aches and pains that I'm having.
I knew this a long time ago.
There's nothing better than stretching now that I've gone out and I bought all
this fucking rogue fitness shit.
Um,
so you know,
to lift weights and all the atomic grips and all that shit to do the a Ninja
warrior stuff,
like the best thing I could be doing all that shit,
that shit's all going to be great.
Provided I fucking stretch.
But um,
okay.
I Dunno.
I wish I knew way,
way,
fucking back in the day to stretch.
There was no stretching in the 80s you went to Gold's gym.
You just did the old,
you know,
you did the stretch you did before you started lifting and Gold's gym back in
the 80s you remember fucking Chevy Chase when he's about ready to jump in the
pool with Christie Brinkley and we wait,
he's going,
this is crazy.
This is crazy.
It's crazy.
You know he's moving his fucking now.
That's what you did.
You did a couple of those and then he did like,
you stuck your arm to the side and you did those fucking,
you know,
touch your left hand to your right toe and up and down.
You know,
one to fucking those military thinks.
Well two,
three,
four,
ah,
love Marine Corps.
You do on that Shit,
right?
Without stretching and then you would just fucking work out.
I fucked up myself so much.
Fucked up my tricep.
I tore a peck,
you know,
it's funny.
All of this shit's going to come back to haunt.
Meet the next time I lose my fucking a health insurance is someone just listen
to this podcast and list everything that I'm talking about is some sort of
preexisting condition.
MMM.
Yeah.
When you probably need one more pill,
you're,
you're doing well.
How do you keep losing your health insurance?
Well,
because you do an acting Gig,
they pay you one time and then they start sending your residual checks for like
a dollar 35 and you have to make 10 grand a year minimum to keep your,
uh,
every single year.
You got to make it,
you got to make that or something like that to keep your fucking sag after
fucking health insurance.
And uh,
you know,
if one year goes by and you're writing a show,
rather than being on the show,
you fucking lose your a,
you ended up loose.
I mean,
I do anyways.
I haven't done it.
Uh,
you know,
I haven't done enough acting work,
I guess.
You know,
you'd think with 58,
fast and furious,
47,
Friday the 13th,
you'd think I could catch on enough to make 10 grand a year.
You know what?
I'm blaming the fucking after sag health,
health insurance.
I think I got to take this.
Why I got to take this one myself.
I got to look myself in the fucking mirror and be like,
you know what bill?
It's your God damn faults your own fucking fault.
Not you just go on and get blue cross blue shield.
That's what I should do and I should just walk away from sag after.
Right.
I don't fucking know.
I'm a big advocate of that.
You know?
Looking yourself in the mirror and being like,
all right,
you fucked up.
As opposed to being like,
you know the world is unfair,
which everybody knows it is.
Right.
But if you say,
all right,
I fucked up that it actually gives you an option to be okay,
what can I do to lessen the fuck up?
Because I know I'm going to fuck up again.
You know,
like if you're like Caitlyn Jenner right now,
rather than fucking filming yourself taking a Piss and Trump's tower,
you know,
why don't you just look yourself in the mirror and be like,
all right,
how did I fuck this up?
You know,
for the first 66 years of my life,
I had a definitive bathroom to go into.
There wasn't any questions,
nor did I have to film myself.
And then afterwards say I didn't molest anybody.
What has happened to that person?
You know,
that that person has absolutely lost their fucking mind.
Who's walking around filming themselves,
taking a Piss,
and then talking about child molesters.
And I know what people would say,
Oh,
you can't have these fucking a former guys with boobs.
Now they have,
you know,
they're transitioning people,
you,
they're gonna fucking molest somebody,
blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
I know that that's what that whole fucking thing was supposed to be about.
But you know,
I don't know.
That just came off to me,
shameless self promotion.
I don't have anything against transgendered people,
but that's fucking dig bat.
It's funny cause you're the big,
bad is the proper word because you know she identifies with the female sex.
I think dig bet now works as opposed to Douche bag.
See I kept the Dhea when I went illiteration ice could never fully,
you know what?
I would never call Bruce a douche bag cause he was on the Wheaties box.
You know,
I dunno about this Katelyn though.
That's what the jury is still out.
Oh Bruce did kill somebody.
You don't accidentally,
Caitlin has yet to accidentally kill somebody.
So you know,
there's a lot of mass to be done.
You know what?
I strike all that.
I think.
I think uh,
she was right to film yourself peeing in a skyscraper.
You know,
whenever I see a video like that,
I always wonder if people who are truly suffering around the world,
if they ever get access to a laptop and it just,
somehow that comes up on their fucking youtube page.
You know what I mean?
They're just living like,
like those people that like Brazil that live in those fucking trash heaps.
If somehow they see fucking Caitlyn Jenner walking around acting like a victim,
you know,
we're in shoes that they probably fucking so together at three o'clock in the
fucking room
morning.
Oh,
I know.
You're supposed to care about everything.
Um,
I don't,
I don't give a fuck.
You know what I give a shit about right now?
Cy,
Anika coming to the providence.
Oh,
so Wurster provenance,
civic center.
Worcester Civic Center.
No.
Ah,
fuck.
I can't even remember.
That's all I give a shit about.
I give a shit about,
um,
I don't know,
being able to fucking reach down and pick up a dirty sock without having a
fucking bolt of lightening go down the back of my leg.
That would be nice.
Right?
Maybe I'm transitioning,
I'm transitioning into a fucking old man right before my very eyes,
you know,
my fucking dog has just been,
he just sleeps all damn day.
It's unbuilt.
I know.
I always bring this shit up,
but it,
it just blows me away.
I walked you around the block.
It's it,
it's all there was.
Um,
anyway,
so I've been watching now as much as I can.
Um,
my wife's been on the road so I,
uh,
I've immediately become a,
a,
a bachelor.
However,
I've kept this place pretty clean,
you know,
and that's a very important thing to do when you're married is when your spouse
leaves,
you have to fuck could show them that you can live without them.
I think that's a huge fucking thing.
Like she so wants to come home and just see this fucking place in absolute like
see that you couldn't live without me,
you know what I mean?
Which I couldn't,
I would be fucking devastated if she fucking left or anything.
Obviously I would be,
but you know what I mean?
You do have to have a little bit of self esteem.
So I've gone back to the way I used to live.
Like I have one plate,
one fork,
that's all I'm music and I just put it in the sink and if I need another one,
I just watched that one.
It's great.
It's nice and quick.
Saves a lot of water.
Right?
Ed Begley Jr would be so fucking happy with me right now.
One plate,
one fork.
I'm really into that type of shit.
And that's very hard to be into that type of shit.
We're now when you have a woman in your life,
you know,
not having a lot of stuff
because,
uh,
bitches be like and stuff.
I don't know what it is.
They can't get enough for fucking Amazon.
I wonder what percentage of people are,
you know,
there's some fucking guy,
but that doctor did a feminine straight doctor that helped me with Siad car.
Um,
I bet he's on Amazon all the time,
you know,
trying to find a new pair of fucking puffy pants to match his sandals.
I'm,
isn't it amazing that this guy helped me out the way he did and I'm so fucking
damaged to the human as a human being,
then I still have to make fun of them.
MMM.
And will,
you know what would you want it for me?
Okay.
So anyways,
the update with the gym.
All right.
I'll actually show you guys before and after pictures when,
uh,
when I'm done because,
it's just a fucking garage.
I don't give a shit if you see that.
So I got the peg board up.
MMM.
I actually,
what I had before was,
you know,
those,
um,
you know those really long pegboards where your arms are really close together
and they're like,
they go on for fucking ever.
MMM.
You know,
my garage,
you know,
it has like a fucking eight foot ceiling.
So that wasn't an option.
So I bought two of those and mounted them sideways.
So I,
it's just,
just do the pegboard exercise sideways.
You don't try to go all the way down and then come all the way back.
And I'm now where they moved them,
they actually cut them in half and put all four side by side.
So the goal is eventually to go up one down the other,
up to third and down the fourth.
I got that up,
I got the speed bag up.
Uh,
that's more for my wife.
She's into that shit.
I don't give a fuck about that.
You know,
that's always,
that was a big thing when I was growing up having a heavy bag and all that shit,
you know,
and then people thought they were tougher because they were hitting the heavy
bag that has no fucking arms and legs.
You know,
you're basically just,
you,
you were beaten up,
you know,
you basically practicing to fight a cripple is all you're really doing.
I mean,
granted there was cardio involved,
but actually I remember a long time ago seeing a fucking guy with no arms and no
legs as a wrestler and nobody could beat him.
They just,
there was nothing to hook and he and he would just do,
I don't know what he was doing,
but he would somehow flip these.
It was like,
can you just imagine wrestling just a rock?
But it was a long flat one and somehow it fucking could move.
Okay.
And it had a head on it.
I don't know how to describe this fucking kid.
All I know is he was winning.
So maybe,
maybe there is something about that,
you know,
what,
can I backtrack?
I don't think I've had one at one point that I've made in this entire podcast
that I haven't,
I haven't retracted from,
well,
you know what,
it's a fucking election year.
MMM.
What's the guy's name was?
Who was the other guy running other than Donald Trump.
Okay.
Hillary Clinton kidding.
Ted Cruz.
I don't know anything about Ted Cruz,
but evidently he's really interested about where Caitlin Jenner drops a fucking
deuce and Caitlyn made a fucking oh,
snapchat fucking video of right.
Is that what happened?
Is that what happened on fucking Facebook this week?
Yeah,
I'm still out of the loop.
Everybody.
So out of the loop,
just can you guys just ride with me for the next couple of fucking months as I
spend my entire waking hours in a fucking writer's room.
I don't fucking see anything.
I don't read anything.
We just stare at a computer screen.
I'm going to need fucking glasses by the time I'm done with this shit.
My Act is drying up.
Thank you.
Know what I'm sitting is shitting on Caitlyn Jenner.
Thank God she fucking made that video cause I ended up getting a great bit out
of it this weekend.
I fucked it up the first time.
Um,
and then the next time it,
it,
uh,
it worked.
So,
uh,
that's always great.
You know,
you gotta Love Topical Material.
Topical material is like the Doritos of fucking stand up.
You know what I mean?
It's fucking,
it's so fucking satisfying.
But there's just no nutrition in it whatsoever.
MMM.
But anyways,
like I was saying before,
I went down to the the uh,
okay.
The comedy store and duty Kenny,
I can't fucking believe it.
It looks like a God damn nightclub.
There's all these young people in there,
there's beautiful women all dressed up and shit.
Just having a great time.
Like it's like,
I don't know,
I wasn't around during the 80s,
but I don't know.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno how it could have been any better just as far as the sheer amount of
people coming out in there.
And they are laughers too.
So if you are in the La area,
mmm.
It's a good time to go down there.
And,
um,
I was on,
you know,
the shows I was on,
it was just fucking one monster fucking comic after another.
That's probably another reason.
MMM.
Like one of my favorites,
I consider him a new guys.
Uh,
Krista Leah who goes down there.
And what I love about that guy is just as a standup comic,
I love seeing a legitimate headliner.
You know,
there's a lot of people that can sell tickets because they're on TV or they did
a movie thing or they took a piss and Donald Trump's fucking tower,
right?
Caitlyn Jenner would sell out of fucking Improv.
But there's very few people that could basically follow anybody go out there and
really level,
like the,
the,
the point at which that you have to level to really be considered a fucking
headliner.
And,
uh,
this guy fucking does it.
So,
um,
yeah,
man,
there was a bunch of people like,
who the fuck was on the show?
I went on if the Dane Cook,
he fucking murdered.
Um,
I got there late on that one.
And then the next show I was working with Chris Delea
and,
um,
the Chashu Lazaro was on Bobby Lee,
by the way,
speaking to Natasha.
Did anybody see the new dice clay fucking series?
I love it.
Did you see age?
Oh my God,
I'm a fuck up.
His name is at Adrian Brody.
Why don't I know anybody's name?
He did this whole fucking thing where he was playing himself and he was,
uh,
you know,
and in his next acting role was to play dice clay,
Andrew dice clay in a bio pic.
So the whole episode,
he's trying to get dice.
I don't want to ruin it.
Just fucking watch it.
His dice clay is his fucking tremendous.
And um,
I don't know,
speaking of the Worcester Centrum,
I've always been a huge dice clay fan and I saw him,
I know I've told this story before,
but that's where I saw him in like 1988.
I saw him,
uh,
at the Worcester Centrum,
um,
with an unknown Eddie Griffin opening up.
And uh,
it was sick.
He fucking murdered.
He did a drum solo at the end of the end.
It was one of the sickest shows I ever saw.
And uh,
I still didn't realize that I wanted to be a comedian,
so fucking dumb.
I was,
when I was growing up,
do you know,
he used to memorize comedy albums and I would ride around my bicycle,
you know,
doing my paper route.
We citing those at those albums pretending I was doing them in the,
in the school auditorium in front of the entire school.
And it's still never dawned on me like,
hey bill,
that probably means that you want to be a comedian.
Like I'd never,
it never fucking done,
it seemed like it was a million miles away.
You know,
we didn't have youtube,
you know,
could just film yourself taking a shit at a dairy queen and say,
take that presidential candidate there.
You,
you couldn't fucking do that back then.
Um,
anyways,
so as always I'm going to talk about another car that I like and that I probably
will never buy.
I was watching something on that Tesla s and it's like the self driving fucking
car and these two guys like computer,
look at guys,
I'll say that because they both had glasses.
So if you have glasses in my world that means you're smart and a lot of people's
world it meets that you know.
But you know I want to be politically correct.
Maybe they were both a couple of fuck heads but anyways they were in this car
and uh,
they put on this self driving mode and according to the video they put blankets
over themselves and they took a fucking nap.
Now Tesla's said that there's some alarming youtube videos of people doing shit
in their cars that you're not supposed to be doing,
but they basically took a nap and then somebody wrote in one of the comments
underneath it like,
would you get arrested if you got shit faced,
put it on self driving mode and then sat in the back seat
and you don't make,
you don't know me.
Maybe you think you know me,
but I'm always bitching about technology.
I actually am coming around to the self driving car.
Just provided that you could still drive it if you want to.
Um,
cause that is dead is pretty fucking cool.
Do you realize,
wow,
how fucking artist shape intellect?
He,
you know,
how bad like this is going to be for procrastinators?
Yeah.
You know the fact that they no longer have to drive themselves to work and
they're going to be trying to finish their fucking presentation in their car.
You know,
you've seen people brushing their teeth or just people literally with an eye
mask on,
just fucking sleeping in the jam jams and then they pull up to work.
You know like you set your car alarm and that's like your fucking alarm to wake
you up.
Like when it stops and is in park,
you know,
maybe the horn just goes bad,
bad,
bad.
That'd be too jarring.
That'd be too jarring for people are the future.
Right.
They don't want to fucking deal with anything.
They just want to lay around.
Right.
So they'd fucking let you lay there in the car.
And I,
you know,
those fucking creepy self vibrating fucking seats.
When you get too close to something,
maybe it does that you're just laying there,
right.
And it just sort of shakes you a little bit and some weird creepy computer
voice.
She could pick the voice too.
Right?
You know,
God knows celebrities will jump all over that they do the fucking voiceovers to
make a little bit of cash because no one pays for movies anymore.
And they're just sick of being in those mighty heroes.
Fucking superhero movies,
one after another.
They're literally out of ideas.
Huh?
I mean,
once you have like the superheroes fighting each other that they gotta be
nervous in Hollywood just going like,
where,
where do we go from here?
You know,
can we reboot this thing again?
Can we reboot the fucking joker and all they'd be know what the funny thing is
so is people will keep showing up.
I guess that makes sense,
right?
God knows they've had the comic books forever and people keep reading those.
You know what?
I'm taking that one back.
I'm wrong about that one again.
Have I been right?
Fuck.
Bunch of swings and misses.
Um,
so anyways,
that Tesla as has another feature where you can like call the car like a fucking
dog.
Like if it's in a tight parking spot,
you can,
you just go here,
hey,
tests the test,
what tests can I buddy?
You want to go for a drive?
Right.
And,
uh,
the thing just slowly backs up and it comes to you.
It's literally,
it's like the fucking night rider car.
And like I said,
I am usually anti technology and um,
but every once in a while something comes along and I,
and I even meet as much as was fucking freckled content.
I am,
I have to sit back and be like,
you know what?
That's cool.
So here's the thing,
the car costs like,
I dunno,
like $120,000.
So I imagine 90% of the people,
you know,
not trying to talk down to you,
okay,
we'll say 80% of you that listen to this fucking thing,
right?
Just went like og teachers.
I'll never be able to afford the EA.
You will.
I'll tell you why.
Okay,
I'll give you,
I'll give you fucking three examples.
Calculators,
rollerblades and flat screen TVs,
all of those things.
When they came out,
they were fucking ridiculously expensive.
And then by the end of it,
they gave him away with like a free tank of fucking gas.
Well maybe not the fucking flat screens,
but you remember like we'll go back to calc worn calculators first came out,
they were $100 each,
something crazy like that.
And then they just,
they just kept dropping,
dropping,
dropping is more and more people bought them and then they had the solar ones
and the next thing you know you got a calculator with the fucking free fill up
at the gas station.
Roller blades were always over 100 bucks,
right?
And then everybody had them and then like,
well what the fuck are we going to do with the rest of them?
And next thing you know,
they was 30 bucks,
right?
Flatscreen TVs when they first came out.
I F I for some reason remember them to be about 11 grant when they first came
out,
you know,
and they were about to stick as my fucking head.
Let me look this up here.
Original price,
original price
of flat screen TV's.
I'm saying 11 grand flatscreen flatscreen falling costs of flat screens
had the farm.
Jesus Christ,
I'll never find it.
Oh,
the price was 14,090 almost 15 grand,
$999 for a plasma TV,
plasma display,
TV,
Yada,
Yada.
Advantages,
disadvantages.
Where the fuck was it?
History.
So we'll go to the two thousands,
2000,
the 40 inch TV cost.
Uh,
you know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
I don't know where the fuck or was it actually came up and then I clicked on it
and then the inflammation disappears.
Um,
sorry about that.
I'm just saying,
so I bet that the test that technology
will,
you know,
it's like when airbags first came out,
they were on Mercedes.
They protected the rich people first.
And then once they got all the rich people's money,
then they go,
all right,
you know what?
Maybe we'll protect the middle class.
And then eventually it gets all the way down to like,
you know,
like there's starving kids in Africa.
They probably have roller blades,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
And like a Chicago Blackhawks 2016,
uh,
advanced to the second round tee shirt.
Right.
You know,
they would get those fucking to get those hats
like Boston red sox in 1986 world series champions.
It's always somebody digging for a blood diamond wearing that shit.
Buffalo bills four in a row,
you know,
that's like what a sex slave tee shirt,
sexually wears over and fucking done on one of those sex slave countries.
Are you making light of the sex human sex trade?
No,
I'm just talking.
I'll make in front of the buffalo bills there.
I fail for the person that has two was sold into sex slavery.
But I,
I don't feel bad for the buffalo bills.
You know what I mean?
You know why they lost all four of those cause nice guys finish last in Marv
Levy is everything that Pete Carroll looks like he is
Pete Carroll is is Marv Levy 2.0 both of them just look like you could just
trust them.
You know,
I could leave,
I could leave a stack of fucking cash here right in front of him.
My life savings,
I will come back and I'm going to be fine.
And that is true with Marv Levy and that's why he lost four Superbowls.
Now if you were to leave that with Pete Carroll,
you know,
I,
I'm,
you know,
I don't think I have to tell you that.
You know,
there'd be some Hooters chicks over there and scared wing sauce on his face and
be like,
yeah,
it's all there.
Fuck you talking about.
Um,
why am I shitting on Pete Carroll and know what you think of bill or to buy your
couch.
What about fucking,
what about bill Bellacheck?
Well,
he doesn't look wholesome.
He looks like a mean dad.
Doesn't eat like a dad's home.
God,
he's such a Douche,
you know,
that's,
that's what it looks like.
Pete Carroll looks like,
you know,
be careful.
Looks like he goes to church,
you know,
and on the third day,
Jesus will rise again and then he's in the back and goes,
wow,
that paty always gets excited during that part of the Jesus Story.
Oh,
um,
oh,
what the fuck was with that guy?
You know,
I actually tweeted about that guy in the draft that got busted,
you know,
wearing the fucking gas mass,
taking the fucking we'd hit and uh,
everybody gave me shit.
You did watch the draft.
It's like,
dude,
it kind of became,
it went viral actually.
Uh,
I was actually texted to me by a,
uh,
another comedian was letting me know.
They said in real time this guy was getting blackmailed and uh,
I ended up watching the clips.
Dude,
that was,
that guy should fire his fucking agent yesterday.
That poor bastard,
nobody,
he had no advice,
but he was sitting there sweating.
If nobody came out is that woman didn't say,
Hey,
hey,
that's enough.
No more questions.
If she didn't rescue him,
that guy would still be sitting there like pouring sweat,
answering ever every fucking question that they asked him.
What's the most fucked up thing you ever jerked off to?
Well,
I would have to say,
uh,
you know,
it's just like,
I don't know where his agent was,
but um,
he was somewhere high fiving himself,
I think.
Ah,
God damn it that Tesla is a good looking car from the side.
I just hate the front end.
It's just weird.
You know,
cause it doesn't need a fucking,
doesn't need a grill cause it doesn't have a radiator cause it doesn't have an
engine to fucking,
you know,
cool off or whatever.
I was going to say,
well it'd be cool if they just put it in there anyways,
but then air would get trapped and then it was actually slow down to that's the
fucking car.
That's the car you want.
That thing is,
it's fast.
It's actually beats a fucking Lamborghini.
It beats a Ferrari zero to 60 if fucking smokes,
that car literally smokes a fucking supercar.
Now when they get up into the higher gears,
this,
you know,
fucking 70 80 miles an hour,
the Ferrari overtakes it.
Who gives a fuck?
Gives a fuck 80 90 miles an hour.
I mean,
I guess if the only reason to want a car going that fast,
if you take it to the track,
if you fucking drive a hundred miles an hour on a regular street,
you're a fucking asshole and you're going to kill somebody.
So,
um,
you know what?
God dammit,
I think I'm going to get that car.
Oh Jesus.
That's a good looking car.
Get it in black.
Huh?
With the red fucking cow pus.
I'm too fucking,
I'm too frugal.
Can't blow hundred 20,000.
What are the,
what's the fucking car payment on that?
It's a fucking moron.
You could buy a third of Detroit for the amount of money you're going to pay for
a fucking Tesla.
That's insane.
You know,
I watched the trashy fucking youtube videos and I really have to stop doing it
because everything,
like for some reason I was looking at the top 10 inappropriate police officer
pictures posted online.
And then once you do that,
then you're just stuck in this thing.
Top 10 things banned in the United States.
Inappropriate family photos that will make you cringe.
You know,
most of them are staged,
but you still sit there and watch it.
The top 10 fucking creepy things ever dug up.
The top 10 weird things in the background is some Hor took a picture of her
fucking ass and a thong.
10 most dangerous gangs in the world.
All right,
I'll look at this guys.
All fucking tattooed up holding the
can have the most dangerous gangs in the world.
This is what I do.
Well,
my wife's side of town,
I watch playoff hockey and then I,
I had that on and then I fucking sit here and I look at this shit.
15 most poisonous animals in the world.
You know what it is?
I've seen every fail video at this point.
I've seen every people are awesome video.
Um,
I seen every fight video.
I've seen every instant Karma bully thing.
I,
I just,
I just feel like I've seen everything that I give a fuck about.
Instant Karmas fails five most dangerous people in the world.
10 X,
10 x 10 actors who actually did it on screen.
I didn't see that.
Wait a minute.
What the fuck is this?
One C and now I'm not going to watch the most dangerous gangs.
You know what's funny is much.
Most of you will make it fun of me right now and the other,
the rest of you are googling the shit right now.
MMM.
So anyways,
uh,
see if I can,
any questions about my fucking,
Andrew sent me the fucking questions yet because I don't have any advertising.
I ain't got nothing.
I'm trying to get this shit out of the fucking way because I've got to do a
radio tour next week to hype all my dates coming up in Florida.
Bill,
you coming to Florida?
You didn't mention that.
Oh yeah.
Going to all the big cities too.
I'm going to a Orlando right home of Disney world now.
Like that small shit out here,
right?
Just Disneyland.
This is Disney world.
Uh,
May 6th I'm going to be at the seminal hard rock hotel and a casino in
Hollywood,
Florida.
Then I'm going to be at the hard rock live in Orlando,
Florida doing two shows.
And then on May 8th,
I'll be at the Times Union Center for the Performing Arts,
Morin Morin Modal Theater,
uh,
in Jacksonville,
Florida.
Um,
and hopefully I'll get their fucking early enough.
I can go to a gun range and suits some fucking guns with silences.
That's some fun shit.
MMM.
God Damn it.
That's a good time.
Jacksonville is underrated under fucking rated city to go to,
I know a lot of people shit on,
you know,
northern Florida.
But uh,
I gotta be honest with you.
I love a shit town.
You know,
there's fun to be had.
Anybody can go to fucking Miami,
go to some fucking Botox party,
whatever the fuck it is those people do down there.
It's like you're not pretty enough.
You've got to fucking laminate you face.
You know,
they're just weird.
I like being in those,
you know,
Tampa,
Clearwater,
Tallahassee,
Orlando,
Jacksonville.
Orlando is not even bad.
Atlanta is like,
um,
sort of like Orange County.
It just sort of a,
I dunno,
it has that mcmansion vibe,
you know?
Um,
I don't know,
but a lot of people live out that way because there's no state income tax.
That's why so many of Burt Reynolds ended up going out there.
Oj Simpson,
you know,
all the people that had rough course cases,
double murders,
divorces,
all of that shit.
You know,
they all end up in Florida.
That's when you know,
you know,
as you get fucking older,
I think he just,
that's,
that's one of the major signs that you were basically a very successful but
married.
The wrong person slash may be killed.
Somebody is,
you end up in Florida if you're not like indigenous to that area.
Ooh,
bell indigenous.
Somebody learned a fucking word,
Huh?
All right.
Let's see if I can read some advertising here for the God damn week.
The God damn week of May 2nd.
You know,
I always make like a,
um,
a mental note to myself,
uh,
at the beginning of May.
Even though I live out here in la,
in the fucker,
weather's always great.
I cause like I'd always just remember like I always be working and I'd be
psyched that Lou was May.
And then before I realized that it was in the August and I was thinking like,
wow,
the first 90 days of this shit,
at least may and June.
I think people,
a lot of people take may and June,
June for fucking granted.
MMM.
I mean,
I don't know who I'm even speaking to at this point.
Does anybody really even have four seasons anymore?
But if you still live in an area like this is the time where you gotta be like,
all right,
let's make the most of the decent weather.
All right?
Okay.
Now for that shit.
Let me read some of the,
uh,
some of the advertising here for this week.
All right.
Sherry's berries.
Okay.
Mother's Day is this weekend only x,
x days away.
Oh,
I guess I'm supposed to fill that in.
Well,
I'm reading this on a May 1st.
So it's seven days away.
It's,
um,
it's May 8th this year.
Uh,
there was no one quite like your mom.
Every mom is unique and we wouldn't want to change a thing.
Uh,
talk about your mom or your wife's corks.
Funny stories or sayings.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
let's see.
I never tell my mother when I'm on TV.
Okay.
Because she's a mom and no matter what I do,
she's going to give me shit.
Ah,
you know what?
I don't understand why you wore that shirt.
I liked your performance on Conan better than on the tonight show.
Um,
no,
I love my mom,
but you know what I mean.
She,
she is like,
she's,
she's my original like Twitter troll my entire life.
I mean,
one of the reasons why I'm so driven is to just one day have a show or a fucking
whatever,
whatever the fuck he called doing a talk show,
a segment on a talk show.
We're wired a wire.
She actually goes like,
you know what?
I sat down and I watched it and I don't have a problem with anything you did.
You know?
I don't know.
Anyways,
that's my Bob going to send some fucking chocolate strawberries are way and with
mother's Day,
just around the corner.
I have a great way to show mom how much you appreciate her.
Surprise mom was something unexpected and as unique as she is with Sherry's
berries right now,
Sherry's berries,
freshly dipped strawberries starting at 1999 plus shipping or a double the
berries for just $10 more.
This is an exclusive offer to my listeners or for people with like stepmothers.
You know,
you'd double the berries and then you split the load and I go to Barry's dot com
click on the microphone on the top right hand corner and type in my code burr
Barry's dipped in milk,
white and dark chocolate.
He goodness,
topped with rich chocolate chips,
chopped nuts and signature wizzle huge,
fresh,
juicy,
delicious.
You pick the delivery date you want and it's guaranteed customer satisfaction is
always guaranteed or your money back.
It's a win win.
Just click on the microphone in the top right hand corner and type in burpee.
You are our go to Barry's dot com B.
Click on the microphone and enter my code named [inaudible].
This is a limited time offer and mother's Day is this weekend,
so make sure you order now.
Uh,
it's a great thing to do.
You know,
it's your mom.
Don't just give her a phone call.
Give her the chocolate strawberries.
You know what,
how about you also give her a little little bouquet of flowers.
Half would pro flowers.
Um,
evidently proflowers is also where that mother's Day is.
This weekend,
only fucking eight days,
seven days away,
six days.
When you hear this,
mom has always been an expert on everything.
Cooking,
relationship advice,
stand up comedy,
um,
fixing your cuts and bruises.
The one thing you can't go to her for,
for advice on is a what?
To get her from others day.
Not to worry.
You're going to look like an expert.
This mother's Day when you use profile Plouffe pro flowers.
Get Mom 100 blooms with a free glass vase for 1999 plus shipping and handling or
make her day extra special and upgrade to a premium vase and add a gore made
chocolate and they're at gourmet chocolate for just nine 99 more.
All shot fire pro flowers is coming and Sherry's berries.
Go to proflowers.com today and use my code.
Burr pro flowers are guaranteed to be fresh and beautiful for at least seven
days or your money back.
You choose the delivery date you want and it's guaranteed.
It's a no brainer.
Here is the only way to get a hundred blooms with a free glass vase starting in
1999 visit pro flowers.com click the blue microphone in the top right corner and
type in Burr.
That's proflowers.com click on the microphone and top type in Burr.
Mother's Day is this weekend,
so order now.
Time is running out.
This offer expires Friday at midnight.
All right,
well we got three more.
So let's get three out of the way and we'll have to left or right.
Mian Oh,
Bodo boot me undies.
Me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
Boo.
Doo doot Doo me undies me on d stick them in a bathroom stall.
This Sunday is mother's Day.
Get her a pair of panties.
What do you say?
It's not too creepy unless you think about it.
Why did I sing about that?
I don't know.
Uh,
get some fucking me on these.
Yap.
All right.
Mandy's,
whether you're werewolf,
they're almost went off the rails.
Whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day and your underwear.
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
your underwear's probably boring me on is here to change that.
MMM.
Every pair of me.
This is made from sustainably sourced modal Madel Moodle,
a fabric that is twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing get described the fit and feel of me undies.
But once you try him on,
you'll understand why they're called the most comfortable Goddamn motherfucking
underwear in the world.
And that is a quote.
And if you don't love your first pair of me undies,
they are free.
No questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help make you make a
statement hog.
You're like dead deck.
You like dead Dick Curtin.
Um,
and make with your underwear.
Well,
whether anyone can see them or not.
Remember Superman.
All right.
This is the offer or call to action here.
Shipping is free.
The U S and Canada and he can save up to $8 a pair with me.
Any subscription.
Yeah,
plant plant.
Uh,
get the subscription or a single pair.
Get $20 off your first order when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar for 20% off your first order of
[inaudible] dot com slash burr
Mandy's Mandy's.
Give them to your brother Tom Badu due to me undies.
Mandy's.
Buy a pair for your mom.
You like both of them cause you're related.
Now that fucking crutches are ventilated.
There we go.
That was a better one.
All right,
I had to make up for that.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club,
stamps.com is what I have left.
But let me go to the,
let me go to your questions for the week,
ladies and gentlemen,
the questions of the week.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
Uh,
bike race accident.
Dear Bill,
did you see the video going around this weekend of uh,
of the Brooklyn bike race pile up?
No,
I didn't.
Uh,
it really makes you question the hive mentality of those bikers.
I've been involved in some high speed activities and their inability to stop or
slow down properly,
properly is mindblowing.
Give it a Google come down to San Diego once in awhile.
Um,
no I haven't seen that,
but uh,
I do know that people on a regular basis fucking die.
Um,
not on a regular basis,
but she definitely diamonds.
Yeah.
The how fast those fucking guys goes.
You're riding a motorcycle without an engine and
Oh,
you got those fucking little shorts on,
get that road rash.
It's the exact same thing.
It minus the muffler burn.
Uh,
but I actually,
I'm a big fan of bike racing though.
I always used to watch the Tour de France and I love watching lance when fucking
seven in a row,
which he did.
He wants seven in a Ralph.
Okay.
Everybody from him all the way to the back of the race tested positive.
So I'll never,
I'll never give up those seven.
I'll always say he wanted those fucking thanks.
And I gotta tell you something right now.
I haven't watched it since then because it's been boring without,
you know,
it's like tiger woods ever since his wife fucking flipped out on him,
and took half his money.
That fucking guy hasn't won shit.
And I never watch golf.
I do like Phil Mickelson though.
I like watching that guy,
that guy.
He's like a,
the guy fucking goes 40 doesn't give a shit.
He's like,
you know,
you're buying a tree.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm going to slice right around this thing.
I'm going for the pin.
Uh,
I dunno.
Maybe you should lay up.
Hey,
look at all this sweat.
I got into my man tits.
You think I'm laying up?
I'm already ready for a fucking Arnold Palmer.
I'm going for the pin.
It's what he does every time.
All right.
Drum workout.
Hey sir,
billion big fan of the podcast and thought I'd share this with you because I
know how much you love drums and talking about working out.
Um,
oh yeah,
recently.
Uh,
I,
I don't know how I,
I I missed out on pan tear.
I just,
you know,
I could never get into that fucking type of singing.
You know what I mean?
He's like,
Jesus Christ,
I heard this in my house growing up.
I don't want music used to take me away from this shit,
but just undeniably Vinnie Paul is one of the great rock drummers of all time
without a fucking doubt.
And I don't think he gets the credit.
I was talking to my drum teacher about this where he's a lot like Alex van
Halen,
who's another one of the great drummers of all time,
but both of them like Alex never got is do I feel because it,
Eddie,
Eddie was just so fucking insane that everybody focused on him and they didn't
really even notice how great Alex was.
And I feel like Pantera is the same thing.
It's kind of creepy how like they both have brothers,
like,
you know,
there were innovated,
innovative,
you know,
dime bag.
He should,
cab was just,
there was nobody liked either one of those guitar players.
In fact.
And then you are asked as fuck to bring that full circle is unfortunately when
Dimebag was murdered,
um,
I always heard that Eddie donated one of his key loved Eddie van Halen and Eddie
donated one of his guitars.
Um,
I think it was that black and yellow one and they actually buried it with
Dimebag.
So,
uh,
I know it's kind of a morbid way to go around and said,
Vinnie,
Paul is a fucking amazing drummer.
But,
um,
I started listening to that song,
I'm broken and uh,
you know,
it's fucking killing me that I can't just sit down and try to figure that
fucking song out.
Cause I,
you know,
I got to sit in this fucking writer's room.
I'm really winded about the writer's room.
You know,
cause I'm used to just fucking half of my days to myself to just sit around,
you know,
staring at my dry me undies balls.
Um,
all right.
Drum workout.
So this new workout saw this new workout where you pretend to play the drums,
which is currently available in the La area.
See the video link.
Wanted to hear your thoughts.
Comment on these modern gym classes these days.
Time to start soundproofing that garage gym.
Thanks for La for the last and go fuck yourself.
Well,
why would I don't understand like guitar hero or even lie having looked at this
fucking workout class.
Like why wouldn't you just learn how to play drums?
Oh,
they're not pretending to play drums.
They have sticks.
Oh God.
Okay.
This is going to be white people trying to be tribal.
Oh yeah.
It's sort of aerobics
and then just playing beats with sticks and stuff.
Oh my God.
This,
Oh,
this has given me Deuce chills.
Ah.
They're like,
oh God.
And they always has to be the person wearing the hat inside the knitted hat.
Ah,
just when you thought that awful look went away.
You know the guy with the fucking skinny jeans,
a tee shirt and then like I'm going to have a snowball fight hat on.
I'm pretending to play the drums is now a hot new workout.
Well they weren't really pretending.
They were actually hitting the floor with them and stuff and hitting the sticks.
So he said there was already a dance from form in India called
okay.
Danya Danya which has the same concept of dancing was sticks and a thousand plus
years old tradition.
Oh,
what a surprise.
What a surprise.
Did somebody already come up with a lot of gifts that gets people in shape?
It actually kind of looks like fun,
but I,
my ears couldn't handle,
I'd have to have fucking earplugs in.
I Dunno.
But everyone was making those guitar hero rocket rocking out faces.
But what would be cool is if that actually,
you know,
if you're taking one of those classes and you actually want to learn how to play
drums,
but you know,
you can't really play because you have an apartment.
I cannot recommend those Rolling v drums enough.
They're fucking amazing.
And uh,
I told you when I had to two of those kits when I was in New York,
it's kind of weird because it's like a computer,
like it gets old and then the new one's better than you,
like because they don't,
if it was an acoustic,
like a regular drum kit,
you just keep it from the fucking drums.
But they get the new brains and they're better and a,
and I don't know,
you just keep,
I don't know.
It's a lot of fucking money,
but they're fucking awesome.
So if you live,
if you live like the way I did what I had a neighbor underneath me,
I went downstairs and I knocked on the guy's door and I said,
listen,
I practice drums.
Uh,
when do you work?
I'll only practice during those hours.
If you're ever home.
When I'm practicing,
here's my phone number.
Call me the second I pick up,
you tell me to stop.
I will immediately stop.
And we,
uh,
we actually still had a problem because the first time he heard me play,
he,
I've said hello.
He goes,
can you knock it off?
And I just fucking snapped on the guy.
I was like,
dude,
don't fucking say that.
Like he asked me 12 fucking times.
It did all that shit.
And then he never called me again.
Fucking dickhead.
Although,
you know,
in defense of him,
I can't imagine what that sounded like underneath,
you know,
not Jesus.
I'm just fucking,
I'm just,
just for attracting every fucking statement.
Alright.
Shoot matches.
Dear Billy bangers and Mash,
you were talking about shoot,
mashes,
shoot matches on this Thursday's podcast.
For those of you who didn't listen,
uh,
shoot match is a wrestling term where basically,
you know,
the sports entertainment,
it's a fake fight even though they really hurting each other,
but you know,
it's worked out.
It's sports entertainment.
So technically it's fake even though they're really throwing each other and
getting hurt,
it is fake.
Um,
what happens in a shoot matches somebody's fucking snaps and becomes a real
fight and starts beating the shit out of the person for real.
So,
um,
he said if you're into those shoot matches,
you should definitely look up a wrestler name New Jack.
The psycho was known for frequently shooting on other wrestlers for the most
minor things.
In one case he thought a tag team was trying to steal his gangsta image.
So he hit them with chairs,
full force,
stabbed them in the head with forks,
et cetera.
And another match.
He basically tries to murder a 60 something year old man.
Those matches are brutal as fuck man.
You should check them out.
I actually saw those.
Yeah,
that guy has like psychological damages,
damages,
psychological damage.
Um,
I knew a guy like that when I was growing up.
He went to fucking cop school.
Surprise,
surprise.
You know,
fucking maniacs who like to be violent.
Like they always end up somehow being bouncers and cops.
I'm not saying they're all like that.
I'm just saying,
it's like,
you know,
people that want to fuck kids,
they're all about volunteering to take them out into the woods.
Not saying every cub scout master as well.
I'm just saying,
you know,
people who want to beat the fuck out of people in don't want to go to jail,
get jobs where they have the afford 30 to beat the fuck out of somebody.
So this fucking lunatic.
So he comes back from like his weekend at cop school and um,
I don't know what he did and he never got accepted.
They just were like,
try out thing.
I don't know.
I came on was so fucking long ago,
so he wants to show me this move.
Then he learned and he was doing it in slow motion.
And then I remember he just fucking looked up at the ceiling,
you know?
Do you remember how like,
uh,
that dude and full metal jacket when he's like,
I am in a world of Shit private joke here,
you know that that thing,
right?
He,
he fucking looked up like that and just fucking full force.
Did the move.
And I heard my fucking wrist snap and um,
I forget how many times I punched him in the side of the head.
I was so fucking mad at him and I was really just mad at myself because I knew
that he was one of those guys,
like he just fucking like,
like he was one of those key was one to let the exact type of personality that
you do not teach that type of shit too because just
he was a dope.
He never felt like he had power in life and then he had this new move and he
just couldn't handle it.
It was like,
you know the whole thing when they always talk like a baby poisonous snake is
the worst.
It's worse than getting bit by an adult baby snake cause he dealt baby snakes
sorta rations out.
The poison with the baby just gives you a fucking both barrels.
That's well that's what the fuck he did.
He had the mentality of a fucking baby reptiles what I'm saying?
And he fucking jacked up my God damn wrist and um,
hey,
and you know what?
It became a fucking shoot match.
That was probably his positive.
Show it to me and I just fucking drilled him in the side of the head like
fucking six times is hard as I fucking could.
I was so fucking mad at him and I remember we were both drunk.
Yeah.
A fucking idiot.
God bless him.
Um,
anyways,
over the head.
Yeah.
That was a throwback Thursday story.
All right.
Fight dear Billy boy band Billy boy band.
Everyone's been asked.
Everyone's always asking for advice.
So here's a rhetorical,
uh,
who's,
who wins in a fight to the death between a silver back gorilla and a grizzly
bear.
One's got Iq and Matt upper body.
The other has razor sharp claws and skull crushing jaws.
Uh,
thanks.
and go sit on it repeatedly.
And I don't know what that means.
Is that like a happy days for us reference?
Um,
yeah,
I would say,
uh,
it depends on if it's a hoe.
I'm rooting.
I would go with the home team.
All right.
If it's a home game for the grizzly bear and they're out in an open field and
there's no fucking tree for the gorilla to fucking go up and then come back
down,
go up,
you know,
do that fucking monkey shit where they slap you in the fucking head.
Um,
I would,
I would say the grizzly winds because
you know,
the gorillas can ball up his fist,
but you know,
you're fighting,
it's like you're fighting Freddy Krueger and he's got two gloves for gloves.
Actually I would say.
Um,
I dunno,
and I got to admit like,
I think I think gorillas a chill,
like I don't think they really liked doing that stuff.
And,
um,
I've watched him fight other fucking gorillas and,
uh,
you know,
there's a lot of clutching and grabbing and shit and I've watched two gorilla
grizzly bears go at it and it's fucking devastating.
Where you like,
how was one of them not dead?
So I would say a grizzly bear.
Um,
I dunno,
and I'm sure over in Asia that they have those fights on the weekends
somewhere in Asia.
They're doing that right now.
Um,
because when I go on Youtube,
I'm just basing that on,
you know,
where you going?
Youtube is actually black and white footage of like lions fighting tigers and
shit like that and fucking cobras fighting these things and you know,
it's just static alligators first fucking cobras or whatever the fuck they was
just,
you know,
like over and age should like the original MMA,
UFC type of ship was actually animals first.
Animals,
you know,
I mean you got to give it up to him.
I mean,
I know that we,
we asked those questions here over an age of they actually get it done,
you know,
which makes means that they're actually killing it more in the realm of a don't
tell me,
show me they're taking the initiative is all I'm saying.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
We get a couple more here.
All right.
Let me read the last two.
Fucking advertising's really quick.
Advertising's advertisements.
She's just crushed.
It's amazing.
They're amazing sometimes that English is my first language.
Uh,
by the way,
I'm 64 days in with my French.
I'm learning past tense stuff.
I can look at it and I can translate it,
but I can't recall it because I have no one to speak it with.
But uh,
I have to think that it's helping me on some level.
I think I'll be able to read a newspaper by the time I get to fucking France the
next time.
I just won't be able to talk to anybody.
Um,
whatever off Phil,
I'm figuring something out.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Uh,
you guys have figured it out.
I've discovered the key to an amazing shave.
It's simple.
It's just me talking right now.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Hey you guys.
I figured it out.
It's simple.
That's exactly what dollar shave club.com does and why I'm a proud member.
Like millions of others.
I'm not a member.
No,
cause I don't like them.
It's just I can't deal with fucking trying to sign up for shit cause even if I
sign up for it,
eventually I'm going to lose my fucking password and I,
it's just a fucking nightmare.
A dollar shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to my door for a third of
the price.
Of what you get from those greedy razor corporations,
uh,
which is true,
both,
uh,
your wallet and face.
Finally,
get some of relief joining dollar shave club.com means you can afford to shave
with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fucking amazing.
And for the smoothest shave ever,
use your fresh dollar shave club bill,
uh,
blade with doc Dick cabbies.
Easy Shit.
Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter.
Uh,
it's not your average shave cream.
It's high quality ingredients that make your skin feel soft and smooth and
moisturized.
Your blade,
we'll just glide gently across your skin.
Um,
if you want the,
the most amazing shape possible,
take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade and Dr Carver's shave butter.
Uh,
uh,
two reasons to join.
Did he used to say easy shave butter?
Dr Carver's?
Easy shave butter.
Now it's Dr Carver's shave butter.
Yeah.
Anyways,
two two reasons to join the dollar shave club.com/bird today.
Uh,
that stall is dollar shave club.com/bar.
all right,
sorry.
The fucking dyslexia is really kicking it today.
One of my eyes is on the word I'm reading and the other one is like three words
down.
I don't know what that is.
What is the medical term for that?
Uh,
Lazy.
I'd alright.
stamps.com ah,
the old favorites is Americans celebrate as America celebrates National Small
Business Week this week.
Stance stock problem wants to honor not only,
it's over 600,000 small business customers.
stamps.com also wants to extend an invitation to small businesses throughout the
nation to help their businesses succeed by reducing or eliminating wasteful
trips to the post office.
stamps.com knows that one of the most available,
most valuable resources as a small business is time.
You can't waste it making constant trips to the post office for your mailing and
shipping.
That's why stamps.com brings all the services of the post office right to your
desk.
Uh,
you can buy and print official US postage for any letter in any package,
any class of mail by using your computer or printer over 600,000 small
businesses are already using stamps.com.
You should try it too.
I use stamps.com to send out any of my posters.
Anytime I'm boring myself out after my shows.
I'm a moron.
If I can figure out how could how to do it.
So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including postage and a digital scale.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in [inaudible] that
stamps.com enter [inaudible] are right here we go.
And uh,
what do I got here?
I've got the questions.
The last two here.
All right,
Tom Brady and Jim or say,
alright,
even I'm sick of this fucking story at this point.
What about Billy boy?
Big Fatty of by Blah,
blah,
blah.
Of course the pats didn't beat the colts by 34 because of a deflated ball,
deflated balls.
That's not the point though.
Here's an example.
If a baseball player is on steroid but goes oh for five on a particular day,
what do you mean?
That's not the point though.
I don't know what point you made.
MMM.
I guess you're saying the deflated ball didn't affect the outcome,
uh,
for baseball player is on steroids but goes oh for five on a particular day.
Does that mean he didn't cheat?
Of course not.
I hate people who do this.
Who Asks questions for me.
Uh,
the point I'm making is that it's not about the results.
It's about breaking the rules.
See this is why I can't stand people.
That's now,
this is not what that decision was about Tom Brady's was,
was his suspension was reinstated.
Not because it was proven that he cheated.
Okay.
This last trial was all about does it corporation have a right to discipline?
It's employee.
That's what it was about.
That's what the NFL was fighting.
Cause Tom Brady opened up a can of worms,
which was basically like where your boss and we said you're suspended.
He appealed it outside of the NFL into a court of law,
which of course it didn't fucking hold up cause it was a complete kangaroo court
horse shit fucking thing that happened.
You know where the owner of the other fucking team hires a guy to find dirt on
the other fucking team,
which you can do on anybody.
Right?
And then then one guy plays judge,
jury and execution.
You take it into a court of law.
I knew that thing would get laughed out of court.
What should fucking did?
And Jim Irsay was looked to be a fucking moron.
So then what happened,
sir,
is they changed their argument.
They then went back to say,
listen,
we are the NFL,
the corporation known as the national football league.
Tom Brady is an employee.
All right?
We said that he's suspended.
We are his boss.
Do we?
Well,
we,
we argue that we have the right to suspend.
Okay.
Um,
our own employees.
That's what it was about.
Okay.
So this is what kills me about all these people,
including Michael [inaudible],
Michael Rappaport who texted me,
right?
He fucking texted me and he goes,
ha ha,
motherfucker.
Uh,
guilty until proven innocent.
Like,
like Tom Brady was racist.
Like the suspension was reactivated,
thus vindicating everybody that says,
Tom Brady's a cheat.
You guys are not paying attention to the fucking story.
That's not what happened.
What happened was the NFL in a court of law one,
the right to suspend Tom Brady because Tom Brady is a fucking,
oh God.
Is there anything more relentless than when your fucking wife calls Jesus
Christ?
I got two more minutes here.
Um,
all right,
I'll answer it here.
Hang on a second.
I'll answer it.
Hello.
It's connecting.
Hey,
I'm finishing my podcast.
That's why I have a microphone and headphones on.
I'll try to acquire it back QUT by,
um,
anyways,
that's what happens.
So I'll read the rest of this guy.
Shit.
Most buffalo wild wing dopes.
Think what happened was they,
uh,
the NFL appealed it and it got proven that Tom Brady is in fact the cheater.
That that was never proven.
It was never proven.
All right.
So I don't know what,
so he goes,
if Brady broke the rule,
then he should be punished.
I don't know if he did or he did and I'm just tired of the argument that sends
pads.
The pads blew out the colts.
It doesn't matter.
Another thing,
you always say that the colts owner got rules changed to benefit his teams.
What rules were changed?
As far as I know,
he only asks that the League enforce rules that were already in place.
Now we sat on the rules committee.
Yeah.
When we beat him and we roughed up as receivers,
he bitched to the referees and the referee said that's illegal.
He then made a tape,
he and a and Peyton Manning,
he made a tape,
went to the NFL and the NFL said,
that's legal.
Jim Mercy got on the rules committee.
He spearheaded a movement to make the way we covered their receivers,
not legal.
Okay.
The cold set up better off fence than we did at the time.
We had a better defense.
He made a rule change that tipped it in favor of him.
This guy is fucking filthy.
He's fucking filthy.
Those walls were changed and why do I have to tell you that?
Why don't you fucking look it up like you can't find it anyways.
He goes,
as far as I know,
he only asked for the no.
Yeah.
As far as you know.
Yeah,
because you didn't look it up.
The five yard rule for receivers has been around forever.
No,
it hasn't.
That happened in my lifetime.
The first thing it was,
it was the Mel Blount rule.
When he beat the shit out of Golden Richards in the Superbowl.
Don't fuck.
Are you speaking in general?
Hourlies I can't fucking say.
I can't stand people like this.
Oh.
And it's been around forever.
Oh,
this global blue.
Ooh.
They don't even look it up.
That's like Versie when VRC fucking goes like,
uh,
you know,
Joe Montana had Jerry Rice.
It's like he didn't have him for his first two super bowls.
He had nobody in 81 he had Freddy Solomon and Dwight Clark.
Those were his number one and two receivers.
And he had some guy,
Earl Cooper is a fucking running back.
He won with nobody.
He won with people he wanted was stars wounded people.
He won't stars,
right?
It's fucking millennials.
I don't understand them.
Wherever it pre millennials,
they just don't look at anything he said Earth or say simply wanted it enforced.
What's wrong with that?
Please respond on your podcast.
Even if you shit on me,
I'll remain a listen or you're a funny motherfucker.
Dude.
That's not what fucking happened and all of this shit happened in your lifetime.
You're just having selective memory.
He fucking,
he said to the referees,
look at this tape.
Look what they did.
They go,
yeah,
we saw it.
That's legal.
Okay,
unreal.
Unreal.
And then they made the tape.
How do you forget this shit?
There was,
it was like a little over 10 years ago.
Go look it up.
That's what the fuck happened.
And then it became,
then it became,
you can't touch him at all.
It wasn't after five yards.
It wasn't before the five yards.
They were touching moves after them.
The physical contact that they were having after that that they were bitching
about,
and then that's when it came.
Okay,
you can do the five yard chuck and then after that bullshit you can't touch
anybody at all.
Used to be able to hand check.
I'm not saying like,
you know that you know,
10 years ago you could fucking beat the shit out of me.
I'm not saying that,
but it's gradually kept moving towards what Jim Irsay finally had was like,
okay,
you can push the guy,
you know,
in the first five yards and then this is the gym or the gym or say ruled the
isn't.
Then after that you can't do anything.
Okay.
Which is why right after that,
all of a sudden all of Dan Marino's records started falling right and left.
I remember one year there was like drew Brees,
drew Brees,
Peyton Manning,
and like fucking Tom Brady were all on pace to break his like almost 30 year old
record of yards in a season.
MMM,
okay.
Because of those,
those ridiculous things that we became almost illegal to cover or receiver.
It was never like that when I was growing up ever.
And if you don't believe me,
do your homework,
go look,
go look at old NFL footage.
The shit that you could do,
the NBA is the same fucking way you could beat the shit out of somebody if they
came down the fucking lane.
I mean,
what Kevin Mchale did,
the Kurt Rambis,
I mean back in the day.
Okay.
That would be like a 10 game suspension,
um,
or whatever it would be.
You'd be suspended for a number of games in it.
And then as far as I know,
nobody even got thrown out.
Uh,
but I am going back like 30 years,
so please just,
I don't give a fuck if you want to shit on my team,
but just do your homework.
That last trial was about a corporation's right to suspend an employee.
That's what it was about.
It wasn't about whether Tom Brady was guilty.
And,
uh,
and for all you can see out there who are just obsessed with this air pressure.
What if Tom Brady had fucking steroids delivered to his fucking mailbox in his
wife's name?
Give me a fucking break already.
And even then,
I gotta be honest with you,
I don't think steroids change the outcome of the game.
They help your personal performance.
But if steroids just met you won the game,
then you know,
teams that did steroids,
they're they,
but they,
when they just go undefeated,
I dunno,
it gives you a competitive edge.
It does.
And you know,
whatever,
I,
I am not against steroids.
I think steroids should be fucking legalized.
They should be researched to the hilt and,
um,
just literally for the quality of life,
then everyone's going to have like know,
I mean,
singers blow out their voices,
they get to take a steroid and they go out and sing their fucking song.
They'll be in the crowd says that they cheated.
Right.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead.
Whatever.
I'm,
I'm fucking,
I'm done arguing that,
especially at this point when all of that information that I just said is out
there.
I might've had a couple of things wrong,
cause I don't have literally the documents in front of me,
but basically what I'm saying is true and I just don't want to argue this shit
anymore.
Okay.
No matter what,
this guy's going to get suspended because at the end of the day,
he works for this fucking corporation.
And you know what the NFL is actually right.
I think they're wrong to suspend Tom Brady.
I think that the,
the investigation and all of that was an absolute fucking witch hunt.
I think all of that is bullshit.
But I do think that the NFL is a corporation has to maintain the right to
suspend somebody.
So if the bus has to roll over Tom Brady,
then so be it.
Cause it's gonna make for a better league because if he gets away with this,
then everybody is going to appeal it outside of the NFL and then they lose
control.
And a,
as much as I'm not a fan of monopolies,
as a sports fan,
it works out great.
Like the UFC is to shit because the fighters have no options.
I feel bad for those guys,
but it's great for me as a fight fan because the best guys have to fight the
best guys.
Um,
all right.
Advice.
I smell.
All right.
I have a car.
I have a crippling health issues since I was a kid.
I fucking stink.
People tell me I smell moldy.
No doctor knows why Colona deodorants can't mask it.
Oh my God.
He goes,
the odor actually gets stronger when I use those things.
Showering doesn't help.
So I am left alone with this issue.
I'm trying to eat as healthy as possible and exercise every day,
which seems to reduce the problem by 50%,
which sounds like a lot,
but still doesn't satisfy me.
I think it's a metabolic issue,
which I don't even know what that is.
And the body is trying to get rid of the toxins through the skin.
Not sure though,
either way.
My whole life revolves around this shit and it led me through episodes of
depression as a teenager and I even considered throwing myself off a bridge or
in front of one of those great white trains.
Uh,
US Germans are making,
but life is actually decent despite this issue.
I can't attend any college classes because of the anxiety,
but I have a great amount of friends.
I'm happy,
funny.
All right.
Looking Guy and my game is,
all right.
So I still get my dick wet.
Sometimes gross.
Can't lock down any girl though for obvious reasons.
I don't even know why I wrote all of this,
but I just wanted to tell you that this podcast and your comedy are really
stimulating.
My Butt's thinking brain.
Please come to Jeremy so we can see your show and I can harass you knows.
Thanks for reading and go fuck yourself and your dog.
Just kidding.
I like your dog.
Just go fuck yourself.
I'm all right,
dude.
Um,
I would just keep going to doctors.
They,
I bet they could figure something out.
You know,
it's gotta be some new agey type of thing,
some sort of detox.
If it's your body getting rid of a toxic,
maybe you're allergic to something.
I have no idea.
I am not,
obviously not a doctor here,
but yeah,
detox,
fasting,
changing your diet.
Um,
there's gotta be,
there's gotta be a way to do that.
I remember a long time ago,
there was some woman that just had,
was talking about she had brutal Halitosis,
which is a,
you know,
your breads fucking stinks.
It was fucking brutal.
And um,
it turned out she had some sort of sinus infection and then once they cleared
that up for fucking
yeah.
Or breath was fine.
So I bet you have
okay.
This I,
you know,
if I had to guess there's something undiagnosed,
you know Helfgott I'm so in over my head.
You got something maybe that you have some sort of fucking infection.
I have no fucking idea and I bet you know there's gotta be something that does
it for free.
If somebody can take a nap and drive to work and not kill anybody,
they got to figure out why your moldy.
I would just keep going to specialists and I,
if you guys have nationwide healthcare over there,
I would just,
that would be my new hobby.
Okay.
You know,
and just keep adding to your file and somebody comes in and somebody will
finally crack the fucking case as to why you smelled moldy.
I bet they can figure it out.
You know,
and then we'll would be great is you went to the alienation of this.
See you got the sense of humor that comes from feeling alienated and um,
I your life will be a fucking joke after that.
I mean,
think about it too.
If you could just stop smelling moldy,
I would think that that's the number one thing.
And then you'd be happy.
You thought your life would be at fucking joke.
So if you have nationwide healthcare,
I would be seeing a doctor like fucking every couple of days.
All right buddy.
It's like you're pulling people out of the crowd.
They hit the half court shot.
Eventually.
It's the,
the ball's going to go in,
I believe in June.
It's few.
It's fucking Germany.
You guys got it.
You guys are fucking,
you know,
half our space program we stole from you guys.
The whole seeds of it.
Audio tape,
all that shit.
You guys had better machine guns that we did.
Ours would overheat.
Sophie killed you.
We actually pit,
we dropped our guns and picked up your machine.
Guns is no fucking way.
In 2016 they can't figure out why you're moldy.
I feel bad for you,
man.
I'm rooting for you,
and I hope you figure it out before you come out to my shelf.
And A,
I should probably know the answer if they didn't,
you know?
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
Uh,
I have a great week and I'll check in on you on Thursday.
See you.